hey everybody good morning happy
saturday it's been a long week and you
know we got about uh 30 seconds
to go before we get started so i'm just
going to let some uh give it
just you know about 10 or 15 more
seconds for people to come on
and then we'll get started now we got a
great uh presentation pablo and i
um you know we like to get together and
show you guys
you know how you can use the tools that
pablo created that i created with
ninjatrader
to make your trading life easier you
know
there's there's no point in making
trading more difficult than it needs to
be more stressful
and you know one of the things that i
like about markers
is that you know it helps me with my
trade entry
right because you know i've always
struggled with but you know i've always
me personally you know sometimes i
when i'm trading you know if i'm having
after suffering you know two or three
losses in a row
you know i start to get a little lacks
in my trading you know either two things
happen one i either get super aggressive
which is bad or two i get
super i'm not super but you know i get a
little bit um
less aggressive and i found by having a
way to automate my trade entry
which is what markers i how i use
markers
um you know it sort of removes that from
me you know because i know that
you know the way that i trade you know
has a positive expectancy so if
you know there are going to be runs
where you do have three four five losses
in a row that's just part of trading you
know sometimes they come spread out
sometimes they come grouped together
and you know i'm not going to be up
there and saying
you know i'm impervious to losses you
know i'm an ice man i got ice running
through my
my veins no you know i'm a human being i
live and breathe
and you know things do affect my trading
you know i got home school with my kids
and
you know sometimes they come in you know
they want to ask me something and if i
get
distracted you know i lose my focus on
the market i could i could miss a trade
entry
and having you know a tool like markers
you know
takes that burden off me so um
let's get started here now hold on a
second here was my screen get my
little laser pointer here so you know
today we're going to talk about how to
automate order flows
flow shifts with markers okay flow
shifts is the new
uh order flow indicator that i released
last week and you know it's been getting
very good feedback from users and
you know it's different than some of the
other tools that i've created because it
reads different things
in the order flow right it's it's not
like
you you're just analyzing price right in
order for there's so many different
things to analyze
you have delta you have point of control
you have
bid volume you have offer volume
obviously you still have price you have
volume for the bar you have
so much more data to analyze
than just relying on price alone so
before we begin you know just do
understand you know trading involves
risk right don't don't trade with money
you can't afford to lose basically
so why flow shifts
and why markers well markers
helps you by automating your trading
okay
and there's different settings of
markers that you can use
if you want to go full on auto you can
you know if you just want to use it
for trade entry you can there's
different ways you can use it and and
the great thing is
you can combine um you know different
tools with it right
and you know whenever i create a tool i
always make sure that
i tell my programmer you know make sure
it plots so that it could be read in
markers right and more importantly right
using a tool to automate your trading
you're not going to miss trades okay now
i know some people that like to trade
in the evening session you know
overnight and
they don't always want to be sitting in
front of a screen you know because in
the night session obviously the volume
is a lot less
you know they're happy to let markers
run
and with the indicator and get them into
the trade
then they could focus on it right i mean
they're not gonna it's a different you
know if you traded the night session in
the day session obviously you know the
night session is much slower
and you know when the market is slow
it's hard to be
focused 100 percent that you need to be
so having a tool like markers you know
can help you
in that regards you know and and even
during the day session when the markets
are moving
very fast you know it's really emotional
at times
right you see you know especially friday
right we had a big rally
in the last hour of trading and
you know it's sometimes you know you get
so emotional that
you find yourself taking trades you
probably shouldn't take
you know when the market sold off
sharply then it rallied right
i'm sure there's a lot of people that
sold that sell-off right because we'd
done that
second on that second leg down right
before the big rally you know
there's we sort of took out the the
previous low so you know it's
a lot of people got stuck right and and
they're sort of taking it because
they're just going oh my gosh you know
the market's moving so fast this is it
we're selling off
we're going to make new lows and they
get they get excited when
and then they start to deviate from
their trading plan
you know and once you're in a trade
then you gotta start managing the trade
right me personally
i like to read the order flow okay i
like to know what's going
on you know is there buying or selling
coming in and if the trade's not working
out
i'm going to get out early
at a smaller loss rather than
let it go and stop me out you know at
the full stop right i mean
as a trader that's what you have to do
you have to trade right
getting in is one thing then you still
got to manage the trade that's that's
the other part of trading it's not just
oh i'm going to get in here system says
buy here
is either going to go to my take profit
or to
my stop okay well why should you let it
stop you out at a full loss
when you know you're staring at the
screen i said you know this doesn't make
sense
what i'm seeing you know i'm long but
all of a sudden the order flow that's
coming in
is bearish then you get out right
don't don't sit there and think that oh
you know it it has to be binary it has
to be either a profit or a loss
no you know you could get out it break
even you could get out at
plus one minus one plus two minus two et
cetera
you can get out of a trade at any point
okay
and that's sometimes what's something
that that
traders lose sight of right if a trade
doesn't start going in your favor
relatively soon chances are it's not
going to go in your favor i mean it
could
but you know what if you get into a
trade
and then you just find yourself under
water for
you know if you train a one-minute chart
if you find yourself underwater for the
next 10 minutes
chances are it's it's not going to work
out
okay i mean why subject yourself to that
and that's where the part of being a
trader and managing your trade
comes into um comes into play
and you know there's there's times where
you get into a trade and so i talk about
when i talk about managing a trade
you get into a trade you got to take
profit market goes up
because within five ticks you take
profit comes back down
hanging around break even makes another
move back up towards you take profit
doesn't get there now what are you gonna
do right he's gonna say well
let it go there a third time well
chances are it's going to put in a
double top and come down and stop you
out
right you have to be able to recognize
when those conditions change
that's your job sort of as as a trader
right is to manage
manage the trade now
markers works on your normal ninjatrader
chart markers ones on ninjatrader 8
my indicators work on ninjatrader 8 and
it'll work
on a normal bar chart as well as an
order flow trader chart
setup is is very quick and easy
and i have a series of steps i'm going
to show you how fast it is to set
to set it up basically for me
once i learn how to use it and you know
it's it's pretty straightforward you
know
i'm not the the most um
tech savvy person you know i know i know
a lot about computers but i'm not one of
these guys that
you know can sort of sit there and
dissect you know how to use
software you know sometimes you buy
software and
you look at the videos and you think oh
this is great you know i could do all
this stuff with software then you end up
getting the software and you don't know
how to use it properly
so that's what i like about markers is
it's
especially this most recent version
which probably released last year is is
very easy to use
you know it's very very easy to set up
and and start running so
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
turn it over to pablo all right he's
going to take you through
um some examples with markers
and he's going to talk about sort of the
difference of tick replay
and etc things like that and you know
what mark a question came up yesterday
about
um markers so hopefully you know if
you're here today i haven't gone through
the list you know just ask a question
there
and then after pablo's done i'll i'll
take you through a quick setup
i'll show you how how easy it is to set
up
an indicator in markers using markers
copy
and then you know if you got any
questions just ask them and and we'll
answer them
um so i see one question
you know john what makes a difference
from order flow scalper
and order flow shifts is it reads
different things in the order flow
not everything is
the same in the sense that you know
there's so many different data points
you could extract from the order flow
and you know if if you're looking
strictly at price
right that that's pretty
i don't know how you call it transparent
right there's only so many ways you
could use price by itself
but then when you start adding volume
volume that traded on the bid
volume that traded on the offer whether
there's imbalances
um what the net difference is between
those volumes etc you know in the
two-way auction in
um horizontally there's a lot
more ways of sort of opening up that
flower
so anyway i'm going to turn it over to
pablo now
and you know i'll let him take you guys
through um markers you know for those of
you that are are new to markers
i think you're going to be uh pleasantly
pleasantly surprised at you know the
capabilities that it has
all right pablo i'll turn it over to you
so you should have a
screen pop up okay hello everyone
i am just looking for the
way to share my screen
i guess this is one yes
let me know if you can see the the chart
with the playback at the bottom
yes i see it perfect so
thank you mike for this invitation and
thank you everyone
to be here and today we are going to be
to to watch very quickly
and fast how to automate and even more
how to filter
signals using markers and
how to solve all those problems of the
tick replay
the time to calculate the chart and
all of that let me show you a quick
example that i am
using today because i have a lot of
hardware
a lot of software running on my computer
so using the
replay may take down my computer
at this moment so i have tick replay
turn off that means that
if i refresh the the chart everything is
lost and this is normal because
on tick replay when i refresh
the chart each bar is calculated tick by
tick
and if your indicator like most of order
flow indicators use
tick by tick analysis to calculate
overflow you need
equatic analysis then that takes a lot
of time to
calculate but the good part is
okay you can enable this option
which is new on ninjatrader 8 this was
not
available on nissa trigger 7. so
when you are back testing
or looking at historical performance
so you are not live you are not trading
live so
it doesn't matter if your computer takes
too much to calculate
then you can enable that option but
for live trading when you are live
trading and you want to
change something on your chart if you
add an indicator change a parameter
whatever
when you click on apply everything is
calculated again from
all your bars on the past and that takes
a lot of time to
calculate not all not only a lot of time
but also
a lot of um hardware resources
and memory so the more charge you have
the more charge on the same instrument
that you are refreshing
because all the charts are recalculated
again
that that takes a lot of time and a lot
of memory so if you want to save
that you can for i i am saying
for a real time trading let's say that
we are
trading i i want and i want to change
just a setting
you turn off click replay
and you know everything will be gone for
for the historical but from this moment
to the
pre to real time it it will work
without any problem now when you are
when you are using playback
you don't need to use a tick replay
because you can execute a fast replay
if you right click your playback you can
set this option
to playback the entire array an insta
trader
replace all the day in in tick mode
so it is already doing the tick replay
feature
so right click select this option plug
back the currently
and then go to to the time that you want
to analyze
for example this is this friday
at the end of the session when you click
on ok
everything will be played back
tick by tick but at a at full speed
i am not a currently we are not doing a
playback we are just
seeking the selected time so it is
painting
tick by tick all the all the data
and believe me this is much faster
than using the replay and refreshing the
chart
i don't know why and even more if you
refresh your chart
several times i don't know why using
tick replay
increases the the time needed for each
refresh and even more what i saw
is that the memory also increases so
each time you refresh
it takes more memory and more memory and
so on
so for my analysis i prefer doing that
okay
turn off the replay
and for historical backtest
just reload a playback
select this option and then go to the
the time that you want to analyze
and that's all now what we have now on
the chart is just a random combination
i choose this is the indicator the new
indicator
the flowsheet and i i
tried to find a combination that plays a
lot of signals
so to show you how to how to automate
that
the first thing that we need to
do is to copy the signals
and for those asking
how can i know if my indicator is
compatible
or not maybe you have a different
another not the flow sheath but the
you know the delta sculper or many
others
that are there markers is using
a feature of ninja trader a
that is named nesting you can nest any
indicator with another indicator for
example i can calculate the ema
of the price of course i know and also
from another indicator for example i can
calculate the ema
of the hma of the sma
of the price and this is what
what we are using here for example if
you want to
check if your signals
from notice but other indicator is
compatible
you can add for example a simple moving
average
of one bar because a simple moving
average of one bar
is the same thing the average of one bar
is exactly the same so you can calculate
for example
the sma of one bar
this with a period of one
and inside here you place the indicator
with all the same parameters and select
the um
the the correct plot let's see an
example
here i am using this indicator
with all these settings and this
indicator has
two plots by signals cell signals
so i need to replicate this
into my nested indicator which in this
case it is markers copy
but if you don't have markers and you
you want to know if it is compatible you
can use
another indicator and try to nest your
indicator
into here for example let's take a copy
of these settings
so now i have a all my parameters
and now i can add
er my preferred is the
maximum indicator because this is the
fastest indicator the maximum of one bar
is the same thing of the input so i can
type
max
maximum this the maximum
of one bar of the indicator that i want
to
to check so an input series
indicator
this one and i need to copy
all the same parameters
the parameters are everything checked
this is unchecked
2 0 i guess it is not useless but just
to be
sure that everything is the same
1 and 2.
what else this is sequel
this is for visual so we don't need to
play this
the same and also
it is important that if the indicator
works at bar close
okay you need to nest your indicator at
work close
this indicator works on interval so you
need to
calculate when you
add the maximum of one bar of this
indicator that works on
intravar then set this to each stick
now when i click on ok everything is
wrong because
i don't have tick replay enabled let's
make this
really big so we can sure
that it should match
the signals and i am copying or
adding a painting the maximum of one
part
of these blue triangles i guess
yes by signal okay now if i click on ok
everything is wrong
and if i go
to okay the the these at the bottom are
the
zeros when the maximum of nothing
is zero
so i need to here are the
correct values and these are the
not correct values so we need to check
that this matches
to the signals
again i am explaining the basic
procedure
to detect if a custom indicator
can be used with markers to automate the
signals
if you want to remove the zeros the
zeros
the zeros are when there is no signal
there is a zero
so you can make this indicator
the maximum remove the auto scale
uh the problem is that now it is
if i do that everything is going again
okay no problem
um go to again sorry for
for the delay now now we are going to
repeat this process with the copy
and now we will see how to filter the
signals
now you can see that the maximum of one
bar of the
selector indicator is correctly
over the signal that we want to copy so
that means
mark if any ninja trader indicator can
nest this indicator then markers copy
will
also do that
okay let's wait this to finish when we
are doing this we cannot
interrupt because we are not doing a
playback and we
we just selected go to
only we can move the playback when this
is green
if i click here go to and then we need
to wait
okay now let's remove this i guess if i
move this from the
no if i move this from another panel
everything remains now if i remove this
no everything remains only if i go to
indicators
and do something then
everything is lost now the next step
the same exactly the same that we did
with the maximum of one bar or with the
simple moving average of one bar or the
exponential moving average of
one bar exactly the same we do with
markers copy
and we go to indicator store as a
i already have it here
i have one for lungs another for shorts
the only difference the only different
is the plot inside
the lungs look at look at here this is
the
name of my blue triangles
and the name is going to be longs
on input series i have all the same
parameters
and the plot is by signal
on the other the parameters are
exactly the same but now
it is the cell signal okay
now
something else if i want to automate
those signals first the first step
should be
checking that what i i am
copying is exactly the same
that i am having on the chart because
maybe i i have a wrong parameter
if an indicator has a lot of parameters
maybe i made a mistake here
and then my copy signals are not the
same
than the visual signals what i usually
do
is selecting
an almost visible dot
you can hide this with this option
because when i copy
an indicator or a signal it will paint
or not another another signal
just to confirm if the copies signal is
equal
exactly the same than the original
signal
so let's enable this
and enable this order
if i click on ok again
everything is lost so i need to
again i need to have the replay enable
or do this procedure go to the same
time and date
and now check if my copy of thoughts
are on the same places than
my the signals that i want to automate
and now we can see that we have a little
dot
over the signals i want to to copy so
this is the first
check now
if i want to automate this
as it is painted right now i don't want
to filter i don't want to do
nothing else this is the simplest
process
i only need to say
on the copies here
that this is a fast signal
simple and also add
a markers
where the default setting or markers is
this
where i am looking for a drawing object
this is the old metal the the metal used
on ninjatrader 7
and it is still available on ninja
trader 8
but i always suggest use the new metal
using fast signals so select fax signal
and here we type the
names that we copied we use longs
shorts and both are fast signals
so here i will type
long and short that's all
it can be simpler now let me show you
something
even more complicated
now let's say i want to filter those
signals because
we have a lot of signals
for one day and maybe i want to
filter um
you know we can filter from markers
so the signals are painted by markers is
filtering with this option
but let's say you want to create a new
logic
that only paints signals when all your
conditions are
met for example you have a signal here
and also you have a filter in agreement
in that case then your copy
is no longer a signal my two copies
are not fast signals anymore now
they are variables now my
i have a variable named loans
and a variable named shorts
that on this bar for example long's long
has a value
the value is the price where it is
located and when there is
no value then the value is zero
as we saw on the maximum indicator
perfect
that means that now i can use that
variable
on another condition so i can
add let's try to find the filter first
for example
let's add an hma a slow hma something
like this
and let's say that when the line is
going up i i want
to take only longs when the line is
going down
i want only shorts
we need to copy that
hma on input series
we select the hma hma
with a video 100
enable and i am painting a
red dot because they copy the line is
peaceable
the name is filter when i click on apply
now there are a little dots just to
confirm
that the variable filter is exactly
the value of the hma
now how can i say that the line is going
up
when the lining is going up its value is
greater
than the value on the previous bar
that should be something like saying
that filter
on the current bar is greater than
filter on the previous bar
now let's add an end condition
now we have two ends one for longs
another for shorts first of all
i am i need to enable this
and this is for longs the name of the
histogram is filter longs
and i now creating a fast signal
and this is what is going to move
markers
the fast signal created by this um
by this end indicator my two conditions
are
first of all that lungs is greater than
zero my signals my long signals
are greater than zero so there is a
signal here and my second condition is
that
filter on the current bar is greater
than filter on the previous bar
simple the the red line is going up
so the two conditions are i have a long
signal and
also the red line is going up
for the shorts i change
the name of the histogram and also
change the name of the fast signal
the condition is that shorts is greater
than zero
and also the filter on the current bar
is less than the filter on the previous
bar
that means the red line is going down
let's take a look at how it looks
making this visible and also the
previous one
when i refresh everything is false
because the red line is going up but
there are no signals because the signals
need thick replay but if i
click on go to
now this short signal is
not painting a a signal by the end
indicator
because the line is going up now the
the line is going down so i get a short
the line is going down i get another
short
now the the line is going up i get along
and i forgot to explain how to
have a separation between because i have
a lot of longs
here but i am only interested in the
first one so for that there is another
option inside here i will show you
as soon as it finishes
okay it finishes because this is green
now i can move the the the chart
uh on the end indicator there is another
parameter that i forgot to explain
we have two ends one for longs another
four shorts and this parameter
is the number of bars that i need to
wait to be interested in taking another
another signal so i need i need a space
of 20 bars without a signal
to be interested in taking another
signal so
i have a signal here because 20 bars in
the past there are no longs and then
i reset the counter here reset the
counter here so
there are no more signals at less
for example this with this is at less
than 20 watts
and now if i want to automate this um
just set the
fast signals created by the end this end
is creating go long this other end
is creating go short that means on
markers
i need to set go long and go short
now the fast signals are created by the
end indicators
not by the original signals
and let's enable this okay
and let's choose
[Music]
an itm
to have an idea which target to use
looking at the chart we can have an idea
of the swing sizes
i usually use a ruler for example
the shortest trade will be something
like here
this short from here to here
we have a 27 ticks so
using 20 ticks for the target is okay
this is something to optimize but let's
use
this atm click
on the atm also
when we are on a different account we
need to
click on the account
and then set to automatic
automatic longs are enabled shorts are
enabled
so it looks like everything is fine
go to okay
and let's see what happens
this one is not executed
waiting start time
i have a problem with the time
um
okay i am waiting for this to turn green
so i can check
what i have
to fix on
markers
let's set to zero no time windows
ok
why it was working
five minutes ago it was working so it
should take a short here
i guess when i disabled and enable
something is not
ah maybe i forgot to enable them sorry
now i see what happens
um
for the next time let's go to 3 am
so i can control this let's go to 3 am
3am at zero
okay
so now we can control the playback
okay now let me check what is
incorrect i guess this is disabled
yes the marker was disabled
okay now let's click on play
now the message is gone but we are only
at
one time let's increase the
time
the maximum speed of the playback
is slower than the go to speed
so it is going to take more than the
previous round
so what we are doing now is copying the
signals
filter the signals with the slope of the
hma
and then execute those signals
and that concludes my part of the
session mike unless there are some
questions about how how to do
anything with this okay that's fine um
let me uh get the screen back here
and there are there are questions but um
we'll get to that
uh in a second here
but no that was good that was useful um
let me just make sure everyone can see
my screen okay
so you know what what pablo showed you
is
is advanced for i think for for some new
users
no offense but um it's
it's good to know you know you can see
the capabilities
that you know how you can combine
different things with
with markers you know and i know some
people
you know like to use you know an
indicator and use another indicator
for sort of confirmation you know like
by if you get a buy signal
you take it you know you only take buys
at a certain level
in relation to like say a v web or
something
so you know you have that flexibility
but i'm going to show you
right now really quick is
how easy it is to set up markers um
you know the first time um you know for
a lot of you people
so okay now this is my my footprint
chart all right but
i have markers on here so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to uh
take everything off start from scratch
what is this this is the ym
chart um so i'll just remove remove
remove
okay so you know i'm just starting with
a
just a simple a simple plain chart okay
nothing uh fancy you know this is just a
footprint chart
but you know if you want me i can just
as use the same process
whether i do it on a footprint chart or
a bar chart okay so there's nothing
different so
let me uh just get everything going here
so
yeah you gotta make sure you have chart
trader open all right um
make sure you choose your atm okay so
what you do simple steps right i like to
keep things simple
go to you know once you load markers on
here um
you just add it on right i already have
my footprint on there
if i didn't have my footprint if i just
look at a normal bar chart there would
be nothing down here
but uh first i'll do it on a footprint
chart then i'll show you on
a on a bar chart okay so you add markers
force i use copy you need to add two one
for the buy one for the cell
um then you just sort you go in here
and you just set it up okay so
it's really simple right you know and if
you're interested in the steps i have
them for you
but i'll i'll talk about the steps you
know i have a little
cheat sheet here if you want i can send
that over to people
just let me know um so you change the
working mode here to auto
enable logs enable shorts pass signal
now you got to change the name here
go along or go short yeah you could keep
go long go short if you want
but i i use my own term i use normal up
for buys normal down for sales
and uh what else yeah i i like to
expand this out 500 um
to 5000. you know that's so you know if
you set the p
l to 500 if you as soon as you make
you know 500 it will not take any more
trades
if you lose 500 it will also
turn off for the day so you know someone
i think that was a question
um before is you know will it uh
you know can it when you reach your nut
so to speak your daily nut
will it stop um yeah that's that's what
uh that's what this is the daily profit
daily loss
okay so that's um that's the force part
now what you have to do
is you go in under
markers copy and you got to set up a buy
you got to set up
a cell okay so uh
i'm using fast signal so i'm going to
turn this on
and change variable name uh where am i
here we are
it says my line change this to what i
put set it up
in markers right remember under
here right i changed it to normal up for
longs
normal down for cells so i'm working on
the ups right now so
change it to normal up
uh and then change this to each tick
calculate on each tick and
you know another setting you don't have
to change what you can if you want
is this you know if if it plotting on
the screen
okay and you want to see where the where
the signals were you know you could use
a dots but you know i like to keep it
triangle up for a by triangle down for a
cell you'll make it a little bit big
eight
now the other thing that you have to do
is you got to go to the data series this
one right here
and you gotta load up the indicator um
flow shifts now you should have some
settings you know you
depend on the market that you trade you
know you you've probably found your sort
of
you know your settings that you like the
settings that i like for
ym one minute chart
is all detection volatile normal low
volume
i use a look back period of 1 i use bar
delta confirmation
and i have balance strength set to 1
balance points
set to 2 okay and
where are we here and make sure this is
the buy signal right so make sure it
says buy signal and click ok
now i gotta do the same thing but this
time sort of the opposite for a sell
signal
okay because right now i just plotted
the buy signals all right so i'll call
it normal down
i'm going to use fast signal okay
and i'm going to change that to
calculate on each tick i'll change this
since it's a cell
i want to see it in red not uh blue
and you know just trying to go down
let's make it eight
so it's you know again you don't have to
plot this stuff on here but you know i
like to have it on there
just to remind me that you know what
there was a signal there then
um here data series again you got to add
the indicator
go to flow shifts set the settings exact
same as you have for the buy
so it's um
all three volatile normal low volume
one enabled delta
and this is set to one but you gotta
change this because this is for your
cell signal so you got to change
the parameter plot to sell signal
and then click ok and should be good
to go almost
okay so you know then just sort of a few
last-minute checks so to speak
you know make sure you have your atm
strategy set up
and make sure it's enabled here right
you see select atm
make sure it's says what it is 25 by 85
here
okay now the other thing is obviously
you got to have your account
matched up right here it says sim this
one's playback
i just click on there make sure i got
the right account
set up and that's it basically
you're good to go now you know i could
run it in replay
um here let me just
get it going here now again so
i have it you know day saturday morning
so i got it on on
playback but when there's a signal
right okay so you see right here
right the conditions were met it got me
into the trade okay so i i'm long from
um what is that 28
okay and then you know my stop and and
take profit
is set to 25 ticks for the stop
85 for the take profit and again you
know depending on what market you're
trading you know depending on what your
your atm is
okay you can um
you set it you know based on on your own
trading
and like i said you know me i know i
here i got stopped out okay i like to
manage the trade so you know question
came up you know will it
will it um what's this
will it automatically get you out of a
trade if you're running it
on sort of this you know auto
autopilot you know you don't have to do
anything right you can see
um last trade is 425
right now my profit is you know minus
70. right now we're
in the the night session
but me i like to trade right i like to
let it
um i like to get into the trade and if
the order flow follows
you know whether you know if it's going
in my favor
i'll let it go to the take profit but
you know what if i'm in a trade right
just go back here
where you know some of these you know
this one
yeah i got in here but it stopped me out
you know in this bar down here you know
if i'm watching the order flow you know
and i see it going up here initially
right i'm long from 09
and i see a trading um you know 30
almost 40 then i start seeing the
selling come in with this red bar
you know this bar struggling to take out
the high of this bar
you know the order flow is just overall
a little bit
uh bearish you know rather than getting
stopped out here
you know as this bar is trading know me
i could move my stop up a little bit
closer
to my entry price right so instead
of getting stopped out at 25 ticks you
know maybe i could have got stopped out
at minus 10 ticks that's where trade
management sort of comes
into um into play
right is you know you're a trader you
still want to trade
but again you could run it on autopilot
right i was running it on autopilot i
mean
so far you know there were some trades
that i got stopped out on there are some
trades that went to the profit target
and you could see you could have up here
your your daily
um you know profit and loss so to speak
um you know up there but again
you know there's going to be times where
you know you do get stopped out right
here there was just two
two trades that i got stopped out three
trades that i just got stopped out on
but i could have mitigated those those
trades in the sense of
you know having you know
as a trader trading it basically you
know understanding
what's going on in the market
hang on there this thing's not here at
the end
okay so now i'm into you know into the
next day already right the night session
and if you're trading the night session
you know as it's trading you can you can
still manage the trade
right even though right here like right
now it's in the night session coming
into eight in the morning
it's down 600 bucks you're thinking oh
you know mike the
system sucks you know it's not one or
two trades you got to take into account
the entire trading day
this is already the next day here but um
anyway that's you know that's the last
couple days right
one day it was like whatever next day
was whatever
so that's on an order flow chart to set
it up on a
footprint chart it's the same way let me
um
let me see if i i'll set it up for you
real quick on on a footprint chart
i gotta wait and i just went back on the
data but
it's the same steps right the steps here
it's basically this all right you just
you open a new chart
turn on chart trader choose your atm add
markers plus add markers copy for the
buy
add markers copy for the cell
then you know you do things you go into
plus this is what you change
okay you go into markers plus you change
the setting working mode to auto you
enable the longs the shorts
enable fast signals mode
change the name to normal you can change
it to whatever say buys or sells if you
want i just use normal up normal down
just because that's me and about sort of
always use that
um you could change the money management
if you want you know if you don't want
to use 500 and 500 you change it to a
thousand
and a thousand or something you know
whatever that's up to you
then you got to set up the buy just
these steps here
change the variable name you know to
normal up that you had set up here
normal up normal down um enable the fast
signal so it's going to read that set up
flow shifts in your setting
and you gotta plot the normal buy signal
calculate on each tick
plot blue triangle up the cell is the
same but in the opposite
and that's really all that is you know
last minute checks just make sure your
atm is
selected turn on auto mode make sure the
correct account
is showing and
um let me
i'll tell you what i'll just i'll start
a brand new chart
okay brand new chart from scratch
just so you can get an idea of
how quickly it is so here let's open up
a chart
and it's on my other screen here um
so basically you just go in well turn on
chart trader
what am i here okay
now
then you just add the indicators right
markers plus markers force
marker go to indicator store markers
force
copy copy all right one for the buy one
for the cell
right you just go in and then you start
changing it
okay so first is working mode where are
we here
turn default is off change it to auto
enable longs enable shorts
um fast signal change it to whatever you
keep go
long or go short if you want but i use a
normal up i use
normal down
and do again you know
500 of these markets 500 is uh very very
very tight but markers copy
all right so now what you got to do is
you go in here to
the settings for the buy okay so you're
going to change this from my line to
um normal up i'm going to use fast
signal and to do and change this on bar
close to on each tick
and again you know i'm not going to
change the plots but again i actually
showed you how to do that you just go in
here
blue for buys i'll change the cell to
red later
but then you also got to go in here to
the input series and
make sure you have the indicator loaded
right with the settings that you're
going to use
make sure this one is the buy since this
isn't buy you guys make sure it says buy
signal
okay so now i'm going to set up the cell
signal um
change this to normal down
uh change that to fast and change this
to
calculate on each tick but again you
know
it's not like you do this enough you you
sort of memorize it
but again you know i do have it on a on
a simple you know
these are the steps that's it it's not
like pages and pages it's just like this
and you know there's even more advanced
ways you could use it you know with
with other tools um
as well did i set this one up here
whoops click here for shifts
okay
change that to cell signal this is the
cell i'm sure that's all right
it's okay and change that to red
click apply
okay so see right now atm strategy says
none so you know i got to choose my atm
strategy since this is a new one
um it's 25 by 85
click there make sure it's there the
account it should be on playback account
so you just click there it'll
automatically change and
you know that's it that's it right
and then you know it'll start running
this is the
normal this is the bar chart okay
but you can see here this is what it's
reading down here the past signals
right normal up normal down
but so you can see there right it had a
it had a head along
then it flipped because it was a short
signal that came in so
you know it got long at 57
closed it out at 60
[Music]
and it looks like it got short or closed
it out whatever
i can't read those so small um i think
it was
three trades one got stopped out then
got short again
at uh at 80 again so it was a long here
then it flipped to a short got stopped
out then it got short again
here at 80. right now it's you know 48
ticks
in profit and again you know if you
wanted to close the trade how do you do
it manually you just hit
just hit close okay
so you know that's how you can get out
of it uh manually
so anyway you know that's you know how
easy it is to
set up markers you know there's there's
more advanced ways to use it
you could use it easily you could use it
you know in more advanced depending on
your strategies i know a lot of people
have these very complex
strategies but you know there's all
sorts of things you know like you could
have
war i mean this would be topics for you
know other days
you know or or crossover um
even you know the slope of something so
there's a lot of different ways you can
use it
um so anyway let's uh we've been going
on about an hour i'll take a look at
some questions
um yes people ask will there be a
recording yep
um there is question here pablo what is
fast signal mode in markers plus
the force you want to answer that one or
yeah sure then on initial trader 7
we only have the option to detect and
automate
objects those objects that we can draw
with the
drawing tool draw a rose dots
an initial trader 8 now we have the
option to also detect plots
plots the plots are much faster to
detect that a drawing object because
ninja trader 8 is a multi-threading
and the thread dedicated to paint
has a lower priority than the thread
dedicated to trade so i suggest
using fast signals because it is fastest
to detect and also to execute a signal
using that mode
okay yeah so basically it's become more
efficient ninjatrader 8 is a big
big change from ninjatrader 7 you know
which is good um let's see
can irani asks a question can you put
two or more
overflow indicators or any indicators i
guess to trade
auto trade at the same time
pablo um so basically
yeah yeah we so that's
that's an easy one um
yeah you can combine you can combine
things um
well victor victor asked about that
cheat sheet that i have that little
step-by-step thing if you want just
shoot me an email
okay um it's simple i'll flip that over
to you i think i have it on my website
and you know if if you don't want to go
to my website and dig around for it just
you know shoot me an email
um okay pablo this one is specifically
for you
uh how can we filter with an indicator
that has two values
eg macd or stochastics
and the filter is if k is greater than d
or default is greater than the average
take the trade etc
yeah you can do that but i think this
could be out of the topic today i invite
you to come to the chat room
yeah yeah pablo has a has a chat um
room um we could ask questions like that
you go to his his website he's
i put his your url up there indicator
store or indicator market
either one they go to the same spot and
you know on there
he has his own um the discord group
right
and you can come in there and you could
ask questions like that specifically
because that's the i said yeah that's
pretty a specific question that's sort
of not in the scope of today but yeah it
is
it is possible um let's see if i want to
use markers
to generate entries on several markets
would i need this so he wants to look
the guy wants to look at rb wants to
look at eight markets where i need to
have
eight charts each with different
instrument symbol open at the same time
or can i have markers run one strategy
on eight
instruments with the ninja trader
strategy tab so
i want to use markers to generate
entries on eight markets
so basically he's asking if he needs to
have eight charts open
or if you can run it from one screen
like the the strategy tab
no you to check the signals you need
yeah eight charts
eight markers right right right
but you could have them you know you
don't need to literally
you could have them on different tabs
here like along the bottom right
um you could open up tabs here so you
don't need to have like
um you know one little tiny one up here
and another one over here
you could all have them on on one tab
but again it depends on you know how
your
screen is if you got a lot of real
estate space in terms of screen space
then yeah you can
you can do that um ronnie asks well i
try to get
well markers get me out of the trade
when it goes against me
well yeah that's what your atm is for
right is
for that um specifically for that all
right it'll
it'll get you into the trade and then it
works you're at your atm
okay um
francisco asks where do i get
flow shifts flow shifts just go to this
website www.flowshifts.com
for markers go to the indicator store or
the indicator market it takes you to the
same spot pablo's got both
just it's simple uh it's the same place
um let me see can you show us
um mike this one's for me in your
workspace did you have a filter to
filter out multiple signals as
pablo showed um
okay yeah you know there's a setting on
there all right pablo so
basically what he's asking where's my
chart here trying to find it
if there's like multiple signals in a
direction
right it just takes the first signal
is there a setting there what's the
setting called i forgot um
oh markers you have an option to trade
only the first signal
or the first two signals and so on
it's but it's under this part here under
the force yeah yeah
um yeah there's a setting in there i
forgot what it's called another one
trace trace per size
okay yeah okay so i have it set to zero
so this one right so you could change
that to
two or three um you know or just keep it
at zero i use zero
i like to take just the for the first
trade um
let's see martin asks
what's the fastest speed you had your
computer server connected to
automated flow shifts using order flows
um i'm not sure that question
i i could say something yeah
if you are only interested in trading
live
and you disable tick replay any computer
can work
you will need a fastest computer
yeah pablo and i were talking about it
earlier um
before this presentation you know if
you're trading
live this you know
his software markers is is
pretty light in terms of system usage
but if you
you you know if you have tick replay
disabled right as long as you're trading
live
then you know it's just it'll run a
little smoother
okay because remember yesterday there's
a question of you know how many charts
can i have open
before a ninjatrader starts to cough
um but you know markers doesn't
it's not code heavy you know in that
sense that it's gonna
you know it's like putting a big weight
on your computer so it's pretty it's a
pretty efficient software
um let me see here
uh any new questions here
i'm trying to get through these i may
have skipped a couple but uh i'm trying
to just go through them here
yeah sally asks um yeah i do have
preferred settings and they're in the
user guide
for flow shifts um
bowmi asks
yeah bomi the indicator store and close
shifts
they're two different websites okay full
shifts is from flowshifts.com
the indicator store is pablo's
markers and his other tools um which
also he's got some other things that
i've got which are pretty
um useful uh
martin says he stated that the computer
is memory stated
hang on here trying to read this
one gig 10k10
well martin i'm not sure you're what you
wrote there one gig 10 gig 10
100 mbs um you know my internet
connection is 300
and it's already pretty quick it's fine
but yeah you don't need you know i've
run this on a laptop
you know staying at staying at um
you know hotels on the road and you know
sometimes those internet speeds are are
decent sometimes they are kind of slow
but you know i haven't really had an
issue but you know you got to realize
you know when you're you're trading
unless you got it running on a server
that's
pretty much you know in the same data
center you're going to have latency
no matter what martin also asked you
stated the computer
is memory intensive so speed and
computer are
crucial you know again it's
yeah i've i've run this on a i5
with what do i got there
um semi just on my laptop i'm just
looking at my laptop specs
i think it's got 16 gig ram or 8 gig of
ram um
you know it's it's just an off-the-shelf
one that i bought at best buy right it's
nothing fancy
uh and i've run it on that i've got
other computers that i pick up
you know on the cheap when they go on
sale that aren't like very big
specs or anything like that um
so it's it's again you don't need to
spend i mean you can if you want you
don't
spend you know four thousand dollars on
a trading computer but you know you got
the money to burn you're sure why not
you know it's always nice to have
something
super fast but you don't necessarily
need that you know even when i was
working at jp morgan
you know we get a lot of our parts we
just call it the scrap yard
you know like old um computers from
other departments you know a person got
fired you know
we've taken pieces from there so it's
not like you know
everyone's running the fastest things
all the time um
yeah phil asked about yesterday's
training yeah yesterday's training and
today's training i'll be sending out
later
um once they get posted um
johnny i'm even
okay well for flow shifts is is about
the license
how many pcs are allowed for flow shifts
and markers for flow shifts it's one
because it's tied to the unique
machine id of ninjatrader
for markers pablo how many when you buy
markers how many computers can you run
it on
two computers two machine learnings yeah
two so for pablo it's two for
flow shifts it's it's one and i said
the reason mine is one is because it's
linked to that
unique machine id of generated from
ninjatrader when you first install it
um johnny settings well
my settings yesterday
the 1597 chart
were just uh i don't have it on here
you know just real quick it was it was
just like this i think it was one and
two
i think i had this turned off low volume
normal markets
no swing filter balance strength one and
two i use delta
confirmation will flow shifts work on
non-minute bars yes it will it'll work
on
it works on obviously tick based charts
it will work
on um
volume based charts it won't work on
range-based charts it won't work on
wrinkle charts um
renko charts are not are not ideal for
um back testing so to speak
and i think they can change in a sense
can the psar
indicator i don't know what that is b
set up within markers plus as a stop
loss tool
do you know what that is pablo p s a r
indicator
i'm not sure yeah i don't i am not sure
um i don't know if that's one in here
inside ninjatrader or something
maybe this parabolic stop and reverse
okay
if if you are referring to the parabolic
sorry yes yeah
yeah it will if it's the if it's this
one psar parabolic stop in reverse yes
it will
um it will work brian s it will work on
range charts
period and it will work on you know for
example here
let me load it up here
um well first remove this
here
just change this here to one
i'll change that to
i don't know what these 10 range chart
um will markers version work to get me
in the trade so i don't need
let's give a swing regular version to
marketers plus basically
um i think the question is
pablo do you still have the regular
version or no no currently there is only
one version
okay uh currently there's one version
um just it's just the plus
so now here's the ten range chart
right on ym
so yeah it does work on
range based charts it does work on
tick based charts it works on volume
based charts so anyway guys
um well brian i don't have the
historical data for
well all right since you're asking let
me just log out go into a real-time
connection here
because you're asking about the 30 range
enqueue
if i got 30 on here 25 30
and q
well pablo what's the price for markers
currently for users of
any of your stuff so for order flop
users we have a
special deal with a 30 percent discount
so that's great send me an email
yeah that's good guys save 30 email
pablo
tell him you saw it on this presentation
and
you could save a lot of money that's
good i've got
the flow shifts is um
saying it's 369 right now it's price is
going to go up
um soon to its regular price of 497 so
right now
it's still it's at its best price um
for users so you know get in while you
can
but um pablo's pablo what's your email
someone was asking
pablo at the indicatorstore.com
yeah here let me uh i'll pull up your
website here
so you see this is the this is the 30
range nq chart
but this is using the settings i have
different settings slightly different
settings for
nq um i forgot what i forgot what they
are
um because this is the settings for a 10
range
uh i forgot what i use here i think i
use
even stronger 110 there and i can't
remember if it was three and one or one
and three
but um okay yeah here's pablo's websites
here well that's coming up
the ender caterer market dot com or the
indicator store
and you know this is what's going on
this is pablo's um email there so
so anyway guys you know i don't keep
guys on any longer you know it's
saturday morning
weathers i'm here in chicago and it was
sunny when i woke up but right now it's
uh it's a little cooler well okay
the question is what's the price of
pablo's markers well on his website
markers plus it's
again it's this but he's offering it to
you for 30 off you just email him
for that special price right he'll he'll
take you through the process to save 30
you know 30 is 300 that's a big savings
so anyway guys have a
great rest of your weekend and
you know we'll see what uh what happens
on monday with the markets you know
what's bitcoin doing right now bitcoin's
still holding steady at 54.
um you know it's to me that's sort of my
market gauge on where the market's going
to reopen or 55
000 now where the market's sort of gonna
reopen we had a big rally obviously on
friday so
um you know it's instead of
having a bearish weekend we got a sort
of a bullish weekend but this is the
you know the 30 range nq chart you know
so anyway guys um juan
it's uh it will be on i'll send you an
email with the replay later
so thanks everybody have a great weekend
thanks pablo for your time
and thank you everyone enjoy the weekend
guys bye bye
bye
you